anyway um yeah read this article about
this lady taking okay well hold on okay
so the article is called lucky the
[ __ ] title is homeless man hurls
bucket of diarrhea at woman near
Hollywood Walk of Fame there's actually
a [ __ ] video of this I didn't see
this before did you watch the video was
the video I just watched their interview
all this sort of um nail is brutal
it's like mid pore let me see that dude
let me see that [ __ ] literally let me
see that [ __ ] click on it so that can I
read this so that yeah yeah go for it
okay a homeless man dumped a bucket of
in quotes hot diarrhea on a Los Angeles
woman near the Hollywood Walk of Fame an
unprovoked attack that's left her with
PTSD she said this week the woman said
she was about to drive home from a Thai
restaurant near the famed tourist area
in April well she's about to have
diarrhea herself when the alleged
assailant dragged her out of her vehicle
that part's wildest [ __ ] dude that's
some GTA [ __ ] yeah that is that is this
a crackhead strength right there he
pulled her into the middle of the street
where he dumped a bucket of feces over
her head she said this is enclosed in
quotes it was diarrhea hot liquid
I was so hit and it was coming off my
eyelashes and into my eyes referring to
the amount of feces used in the attack
paramedics who treated her said that it
looked like the man was saving it up for
a month yeah bro
she said she has to go in for every
three months for like STD checks and
like just general disease to make sure
she's good bruh dude that raw I can't
imagine how [ __ ] scarring that would
be I'd have to kill him I would have to
kill him he'd be forced to kill him I
just dude listen man sorry I gotta kill
ya I got yes you [ __ ] up
yeah man it's you had a good run just
pow there's no way there's no way I
could survive that like psychologically
yeah no I shall be ruined
I'd be ruined just knowing that just
might have some [ __ ] disease bro no
way the smell dude was probably just I
can't even imagine dude the way she like
describes it in her interview is like oh
wait there's an interview with her yes
the way she says it though it doesn't
even sound like it's um light like it's
like it's real like it almost sounds
like a bit like just the way she's
described she's like ah it was
horrifying it was just hot liquid what's
down my eyelids and I started getting
hard the more she kept talking about
stops you're like what is this a shocker
podcast just [ __ ] just scat play
fetish ASMR you're hot I was I was
talking about this with with Devin and
he was like he was like there was
there's no way it was hot I was like
what you mean he's like no it was it was
like like room temperature at the most
to have to have like be hot you'd have
to microwave it I mean yeah you think
this guy like like stole a bird and like
took out the battery and like hook it up
to like a Mike microwave that he found
somewhere and heat it up this [ __ ] no
bro well does it say what time of the
day this happened cuz if it's like a
hot-ass day in Hollywood the [ __ ] in
that hole a part of LA gets hotter than
everything else in LA so that's true I
guess you could just leave it out in the
Sun and it could heat up sufficiently
yeah if it's if it's during the day I
mean [ __ ] is hot in general so kind of
like this was clearly planned I mean bro
you got to figure this dude is like just
like untreated oh yeah untreated addict
or something and he that what with that
whole action we don't even know what he
saw in his own mind that is crazy bro
saving your [ __ ] for months just just
pooping in a bucket not pooping diarrhea
in a bucket oh man this is crazy to know
that fate had somebody's name on that
bucket like from day one you know say
yeah she said she it said there's
another article set here saying she
thought it was an acid attack yeah
probably just based on the smell I would
probably think it was acid too I mean it
probably qualifies as acid I thought it
was an acid attack it started to go down
and on my head and into my eyelashes and
that's when I realized no it's you see
clearly like she clearly dude that's
crazy that he dragged her out of the
[ __ ] car I thought she was just
walking down the street and got
splish-splash you know but she's got rag
out over a car she was probably
horrified there just la just gonna
designate like a splash zone like you're
gonna have to go down the Walk of Fame
with a poncho and [ __ ] high goggles
it's like what's that [ __ ] game show
where they got slimed at the end or
whatever on Nickelodeon what was that
called double dare no bro is called uh
oh please don't tell the Canadians [ __ ]
oh it was Canadian holy [ __ ] I was gonna
we had a different name for this [ __ ] in
America oh my god it's [ __ ] what is
this show goddamn it that's what I
pictured when I read this article just a
big bucket of green
she's getting slimed and she's like
smiling no I think it was I think it was
double there I swear it was doubled
there dude if you guys know if anyone
knows uh-oh
you gotta let me know about that in the
comments because I know I really was
like one of my favorite shows as a child
watching people get slimed
it's double dare for America you know we
get hit by the giant trough of homeless
[ __ ] in the game show
it was homeless dude [ __ ] a [ __ ]
storm drain worth of homeless [ __ ]
pouring down on your goddamn head dude
that's so funny now they're gonna have
to put up signs on Hollywood Boulevard
like warning hot diarrhea attacks you
know like when you go to a [ __ ]
haunted house and like like a whole area
and there's like the [ __ ] disclaimer
the barricade its dude it's basically
gonna be like that's our version of
Bourbon Street but instead of liquor
it's [ __ ] homeless feces Jesus Christ
dude I say all this and like I'm like
inside and Elena's outside on the patio
enjoying the beautiful view right now
imagine it's like a movie or just in
here like hot homeless Dookie and cut to
her outside just breeze
[Music]